what is a monopolist it's a firm or
entity that can dictate everything the
price the quantity and the quality of a
product because it's the only one that
sells that product haha customers may be
forced to accept high prices and poor
quality there have always been
monopolists throughout the 17th and 18th
centuries for example the Dutch East
India Company controlled the valuable
spice trade between India and Europe the
20th century saw a monopoly on the sale
of matches
there was only one company selling
batches in 16 countries felt Holzer in
1930 a Swedish entrepreneur known as the
match king gave the German government
alone of 500 million rice marks in
return he obtained the exclusive rights
to sell his matches in Germany this
monopoly didn't end until 1983 in 1890
the United States became the first
country to begin tackling monopolies the
Sherman Antitrust Act made it illegal to
monopolize a market Germany followed
suit in 1958 the EU only introduced an
antitrust law in 2003 in 2013
competition regulators slapped a fine on
Microsoft the US software giant had to
pay 561 million euros to the European
Union for failing to promote browsers
from other companies in extreme cases a
company may have to be broken up because
of its monopoly but it's national
governments that often have the biggest
monopolies for decades the German
government run lucrative businesses like
the Postal Service and the lottery
Germany's rail network is still owned by
the state monopolies often develop as a
result of inventions which initially
control the market like the first mobile
phones from Motorola for example or
photocopiers from Xerox
everyone wants the product so customers
are generally not bothered if the
company has a monopoly